gentlemen welcome to the forge I'm sure
you guys noticed my collection of
vintage golf gear I assure you we're not
hitting the links today you'll be
forging signature blades harvested from
the steel in these golf clubs golf clubs
what just to make things more
interesting I'm also including the golf
ball size bearing a 52-100 high carbon
chromium steel that you must also
incorporate into your blade
I was happy to see the ball bearing I
know what to do with that but golf clubs
who makes Knives Out of golf clubs good
luck gentlemen in your 10 minute design
window starts
now what I'm going to make is a combat
Camp knife gives you a little more
leverage when you're cutting I'm
anticipating having to do a sand my
construction forging out the heads of
those golf clubs and sandwiching that
bearing steel between it the hardest
part about using the golf clubs is how
to put the steel together probably the
best way put ahead of at least two of
the golf clubs on a sandwich Forge weld
them together and make a blade that way
my plan is to make a camp night it has a
wide belly and it should cut right
through that meat
Nicholas was tasting the clubs
I do this all the time with steel to see
if I can tell what it is
[Music]
you can try to tell a little bit
sometimes by The Taste on it hey man
everybody got their way the head is
probably the most usable object this the
shaft is seems to be mild steel not a
high carbon steel I think the sacks is
very simple straight edge slightly
curved back it's a shape that stand the
test of History blade Smith's your 10
minute design window is closed your
three hour Forge time starts now
Dustin's right to the Press with the
ball bearing it hasn't been in the Forge
that long ideally you want more heat it
doesn't want to move too well when you
get it below 1500 degrees
oh knock this bearing right off this
stick fire on the floor
hello Mr Golf Club
I'm gonna make a knife out of you I
believe that Nicholas is going to be
very entertaining
my plan is to do a sandwich sort of
thing with the ball bearing in the
center and the Mystery metal of the
putters on the outside flatten those out
into a bar shape stack all three
together
and then just smash it flat
smash
I've drawn out a sub Tang this is a high
carbon steel I'm going to weld it to the
low carbon so the low carbon will all be
in the Tang Now dust it into the high
carbon steel Billet in a low carbon
steel it's going to attach them at this
juncture as long as it's forged welded
together it should be just fine
Steven's got his steel forwards welded
together and he's drawn out his piece
really nice it's looking great I'm
thinking hey you know looks like I got a
good weld
nope nope nope it just popped up on the
end did you see that I'm going to cut
off those little bee lamps that run
across the blade hopefully that's going
to fix this I think that that's a smart
move God willing the blade basic shape
is all there rather than having to drill
the holes after it's probably hardened
I'm punching the holes for the scales
for the 10.
drifting holes is not the easiest thing
in the planet to do well knows your
skills you develop over a lot of times
yeah almost made for Hobbits yeah
one time I got the advantage
I've got my forged welding done the Tang
took it's a little thinner than what I
wanted it to be at that Junction but
this will work at this point I've got to
get the blade hardened if it's not
hardened
it's not a blade I don't know
I don't know look at Dustin's Junction
right now you've got two pieces of
material coming together at what is the
thinnest spot on that entire blade or
log chop that could possibly be a
catastrophic failure
we're gonna do a little old-fashioned
heat treating
so I'm heating this edge up with the
torch and I'm seeing those little B
Lambs Elam City and I'm just praying
that they aren't going to come apart
further in testing that's the very thing
that can send you home Steven is
quenched Dustin has clinched
Nicholas is quenched
the fires of Mordor over there
three two one blade Smith drop your
tools shut down your machines
gentlemen this is the strength test I'll
be testing to strength and durability of
your knives by chopping into this piece
of wood 10 times Steve are you ready
absolutely you better be
I've looked at my blade I've looked at
the other blades I I know the type of
Blade that I've made is a very good
chopping knife so I'm confident this
blade is going to perform well
[Applause]
Stephen I love the edge geometry you
have right here I hate the handle
geometry you have right here this handle
is very difficult to hang on to
I don't like to have to think about how
I'm holding the knife and re-gripping
and re-gripping and I'm cutting this I
had to do that several times
well it cut it's sharp there's no damage
to the edge
Nicholas you're next
I am totally confident it'll meet all
the criteria it'll drop a chunk of wood
it'll slice a ham in half
and it won't break doing it so there
foreign
but it is not my favorite shape that
I've ever seen on the night yeah
I appreciate that you put three lanyard
pins in it and I use this one for the
lanyard which worked good however you
handle being very skinny makes it
difficult to keep it from ratcheting out
of my hand and if it wasn't for that
lanyard it would have wiggled out if
we're designing a knife for chopping I
don't want to have to think about that I
just want to let the tool do the work
but it was sharp there's no damage
overall not bad Dustin
are you ready hell yeah all right
I feel pretty confident going into
testing I know my handle's strong I know
my Blade's strong but that Junction
between the blade and the Tang itself
worries me a little bit
I do like your usage of the what was
that Golf Club yeah it was on the golf
club now
you know our concern was your tang in
here you had very weak weld
you wisely chose carbon fiber to you
know bind that up however there's a
significant crack between the carbon
fiber and the G10 on this side and the
front where your hardened steel was
forged welded to the softer steel has
broken that's the only thing that could
have happened here that was what we were
afraid of in the first place and it
makes it unsafe to use
fair enough
Dustin due to the critical failure in
your blade we cannot continue with the
testing
therefore I have to ask you to please
leave the forge thank you
yes sir I would not disagree with the
judge's decision the failure was
something that I had somewhat
anticipated I really listened to the
judges about what they said about
strengthening the tang and I did my damn
distance it just didn't work
foreign
[Music]